[Music]
[Applause]
with that we bring you Brian Costello
the jet stream reporter of the New York
Post Yeah I'm a master of Segways there
Ryan thanks uh thanks for joining us
um explain what happened yesterday with
the Jets and how would Jets fans or
should they feel about what they're
doing right now
on Maximus nonsense right now Dan with
the Jets beat uh look they had to do
something they had to bring a
quarterback there was no good answers
out there for them uh so you know Trevor
Simeon is the guy that's going to come
in
you know he's a veteran he he I think he
probably knows the West Coast offense a
little bit although he's not going to
play this week but they can get him
ready and and if Zach Wilson falls on
his face on Sunday night maybe you see
him in two weeks in Denver but there's
there's no answers right now Dan that's
I mean that's fans are just screaming
you know get a quarterback and you know
they're throwing out these crazy
scenarios of Kirk Cousins and you know
Vikings aren't trading Kirk Cousins
right now so
um that's really there's nothing they
can do at this at this moment so Trevor
assuming it is why not bring in Trevor
Simeon a couple of weeks ago
yeah that's a good question man it's
fair uh and I think you know a few weeks
ago they initially tried with Chad Henny
uh because he had played for Nathaniel
Hackett in Jacksonville they they
thought about Brett Rippin who was on
the practice squad with the Rams and the
Rams signed him uh onto the active
roster because he played for Hackett
last year in Denver so I think they were
looking for direct links and
you know I I don't know what what's
what's better about Trevor Simeon now
than two weeks ago other than maybe what
they saw Sunday from Zach Wilson said
okay we really need to get somebody in
here now when I watched the game I know
that the blame is put on Zach Wilson but
yeah I I mean that offensive line is not
very good
uh so I take Aaron Rodgers out of the
equation and somehow this is one of the
worst teams in the NFL how is that
possible
yeah I think the offensive line played
better Sunday than honestly than they
have they they move some pieces around
there's some different starters but
you know I I've I've learned through
years of doing this Dan that there's two
types of quarterbacks there's ones that
hide the warts on a team and ones that
expose them and the Jets were counting
on Aaron Rodgers to be the guy that hit
all the warts when there were concerns
about the offensive line and training
camp and there were real concerns we
talked about it then
the answer you've always got well
Aaron's gonna get the ball get rid of
the ball quickly so it'll be okay
because he'll get rid of the ball
quickly and when you said ah our Alan
Lazard and Randall Cobb are those really
like those really good two three options
on this team well Aaron likes them he
played with them in Green Bay he's
comfortable with them it'll be okay
because Aaron's here
and then all of a sudden four plays
hidden Aaron wasn't here anymore and the
Jets you know the backup plan was not a
good one and I'm not sure if there was
any good backup plan Dan out there I
guess they could have cast Zach Wilson
aside in in January and gone with like a
gardener mint shoe something like that
it would look better I get that but I
think the Jets were as an organization
said let's try to see if we can
rehabilitate this kid
and not play him for a couple years and
have Rogers here and maybe we can fix
them and obviously that plan has got up
in smoke and then it feels like there's
infighting as sometimes you'll see a one
side of the ball that's better than the
other side or or is the media sort of
making this a little more than what it
is I haven't seen the infighting between
the defense and the offense yet Dan I I
I think the defense has been pretty good
about not doing that the infighting's
been within the offense and that was
clear on the sideline the CBS cameras
caught it you know Michael Carter the
running back yelling at the running
backs coach Taylor Embry Garrett Wilson
kind of throwing his hands up and
frustration as they were looking at a
tablet you know they're the players are
frustrated right I I think where we're
at Dan is Jets the Jets Universe Jets
players coaches fans have are going
through the five stages of grief and
right now you know I think denial hit
right that night it was like oh my God
this can't happen then there was anger
right oh Jets fans can't have nice
things then there was the bargaining ban
it was well maybe Zach Wilson's going to
be better now because he was with Rogers
now we've hit depression and the whole
place is I think the whole place is
depressed and it's like man we've got 14
more games what are we gonna do they
thought they were going to the Super
Bowl Dan they legitimately thought this
was a Super Bowl team and now they're
one and two with the Kansas City Chiefs
coming in here Sunday night they've got
the Eagles in two weeks make the
schedules brutal for them to try to
write the ship here uh so you know I
don't know when acceptance arrives Dan
but I think we're a few weeks away from
that where are we in a month
it's a great question
um you know like I said Chiefs Eagles is
tough they do go to Denver and play the
Broncos they they need to come out of
this first six games two and four Dan
they have a buy after the Eagles game so
the first six games in a buy
the whole even with Aaron the thought
was off they go three and three they'll
be all right because the schedule
lightens up after the buy I think if
they can win in Denver you know two and
four they can right this ship a little
bit like and I say right the ship that's
not playoffs that's seven eight wins not
a disaster of a season but I think that
that's where they're at right now Dan
can anybody lose their job this season
so the hard part with that one is Aaron
Rodgers role right Roger said he wants
to come back Rogers has been a fan of
Robert Sala Roger's been a fan of Joe
Douglas does Aaron come to Woody Johnson
say you know what I I I if they if
they're not coming back I'm not coming
back if they can if if solid and Douglas
have Rogers in their corner I think
they're back if this season's a disaster
and and they don't have that then yeah I
think people can lose their jobs would
you rather watch the Jets play or watch
Aaron Rodgers watch the Jets play
that's a good question dude I I what I'm
hoping is that we're not watching Taylor
Swift watch the Jets play outside
I have this I I feel for Gen I feel
horrible for Jessica as they're gonna
sit there and watch your team get
demolished and here all night from Mike
Tarico about Taylor Swift but yeah is
Taylor gonna be there
that's the that's the big question right
now dude that's really the only drama
surrounded in this game is Taylor going
to be in the building and trust me I
work at the New York Post oh yeah I'm
getting that question quite a bit from
people that work at the interpost right
now so you know but I I that that's the
story right now but yeah the Rogers
thing going on McAfee each week and kind
of he just adds another layer to this
right because our back page today Dan is
Aaron Rodgers talking about everything
yeah and I think it's Aaron of
grievances is the is the back page today
so it's like and every time he talks he
makes news so this is just it's just
I've seen I've seen some wacky jet
seasons
this is going right to the right right
near the top of them Dan or the bottom
uh whichever way you want to go Brian
thanks for joining us safe travels uh to
the Jets facility thanks for joining us
thanks Dan that's Brian Costello he
covers the Jets for the New York Post